so a five-year project how many hours of
footage I don't know hundreds of hours
of footage obviously and see um
everything from 35 millimeter film ins
in this project to YouTube clips so it
was a bigger project as we've ever
worked on I did want to kind of add a
note to the to the mermaid story is that
it very very early on Steve and I first
came to today banana with this concept
and I said said what about the mermaid
like Eva all this stuff for the boys in
there where's old stuff for the girls ah
interesting it's it takes a lot of
different styles to reach everybody
whether it be a surfer or whether it be
someone who's interested in what the
celebrities are doing our kids who care
about their you know plastic bags it
takes all sides and as a filmmaker is
really interesting to sit back and
listen to that and sort of listen to it
from the players who were involved and
and to say hey how do I incorporate all
these very interesting people and these
ideas into this film which is sort of
how Isabelle got involved is well I like
I didn't really know her very much until
he went to a blues fest and and we're
bringing up the visual petition and then
met her when when we came to Japan for
the for the battle out and found that
here was someone who could lend their
celebrity in a way that was way bigger
than my camera could ever do so it's
interesting to see how you can hear
input from other people whether it be
about female involvement about the
mermaid about celebrity involvement surf
rats the whole deal
really real really interesting that way
but um I sort of want to want to know
why Isabel's here and why she sort of
jumped into a project like this for tell
Bob why wat that Caiaphas cotton ball
and I think it was it wasn't the boys
fessed a little bit about a couple weeks
before my friend sent me this YouTube
video of the footage of what was
happening in japan and i think it's the
glove work with slight remember it
wasn't the name of it that's okay and I
I haven't ever seen footage of and said
a lot of animal documentary I'll sorry
animal slaughter documentaries about how
it works in slaughterhouses and I
haven't ever seen any footage quiet as
devastating as this and I just remember
thinking I think I belong with not
knowing what I could do to help and at
the time I had this audition or a film
called daybreakers and the character of
the film's was on betrayed my father and
was really her Barbie doll by and I
remember trying to channel the fear
that I had after watching this this um
this footage and I was so emotional so
passionate and I really tried to bring
it into the scene i havenít up getting
some height as well actually and so but
then a week later I was at this music
festival animate a.m. and they were held
a were doing the visual petition and
that was just a small way something that
I could do and then I kept self educated
about the issue and wanting to be
involved in just anything i could do so
i guess that's how I